so with that I'd like to introduce
Teresa and Teresa works for the Calgary
Board of Education she is a dedicated
trauma-informed educator with over 20
years of experience working with
children and adolescents her experience
spans public and private education
elementary junior and senior high
divisions as well as Sigrid segregated
and inclusive settings from her vantage
point as a classroom teacher Calgary
Board of Education behavior strategist
mental health specialist and most
recently assistant principal in unique
setting for students diagnosed with
severe externalizing behaviors Theresa
sees how to link emerging brain-based
science with best teaching practice well
first I just want to say it's the last
day of school and so yeah so I'm a
little exhausted and I realize I'm
losing my voice heading into my summer
cold so that should be tomorrow so but
I'm gonna do my best here to in a very
short period of time cover quite a bit
of a material but one of the the things
that I want to to just say is really the
point of what I'm going to talk about is
how do we get this thing going here how
are we gonna link some of that science
information which has been so helpful in
my own practice to the school setting
and look at a couple of really simple
frames on how do we help the
professionals that we're working with
look at those things and then also
taking a little bit of a look at the
education model itself and some of the
challenges and entry points when we are
trying to look at ways to bring this
information into schools and in a lot of
ways what I'm going to talk about is
gonna set the context for for Margaret
to follow up we we tend to present
together so Margaret as a mental health
professional and myself as an educator
and so we just play off each other so
it's a little weird for me to be up here
without knowing she's going to jump in
and take over when need be so but the
most important bit of information really
is that there's absolutely no question
that those rich healthy environments are
best right and and that's that's what we
would wish for every child before they
enter school is that they've had that
exposure we know that that creates
better results for learners so the
reality is that a high percentage I
shouldn't say a higher percentage a
percentage of students coming in have
high aces or adverse childhood
experiences before entering school which
can create a deficit for learning if
we're gonna add in some of those low
social economic status and maybe even
that I want to note learn more from Tom
about the social subordination piece I
think that's really interesting as well
to see how that plays out in the school
but I think definitely when you start to
put these pieces together we see kids
out more of a disadvantage for learning
so when I first started to hear about
some of this science my thoughts were
that really what I needed to do as a
strategist working with adults for the
first time was that I needed to get in
and really help people understand how to
target that individual student that we
were worried about and I was having a
bit of a low success rate with that so
started to look at out why that might be
so I'm working off notes here today guys
so pardon the page flipping but what we
did Margaret and I had our info
management department pull out just some
random classrooms for us to take a look
at a bit of a cross-section of what was
happening in classrooms so we could
share that with you and even we were
surprised when we saw it kind of in
black and white like that
so what I've done here is taken a class
of 24 and I haven't really changed the
number of identified needs in the
classroom but I did change the type of
need just to give us a better sense of
maybe the cross section so in this in
this classroom this kind of fictitious
classroom with some basis in reality on
the top corner is a
FASD so fuel alcohol syndrome first
nation matey or into it students there's
a couple in there several English
language learners in our in our city in
classrooms some dual diagnosis so kids
coming out with a diagnosis of we call
them code 42 or severe behavior with a
with ADHD and down at the bottom also
with learning disabilities quite common
to see those kind of mixes kids with
learning disabilities
perhaps cognitive delays in the
elementary classroom autism spectrum
disorder and communication so these are
a sample of things that could be present
in the classroom and when we look at
that and when we're saying well you know
why don't you just kind of take care of
this kid that we're worried about it
becomes really clear right the
complexity of the classrooms is is is
very very challenging so when we looked
at junior high and senior high the
numbers decreased a bit this was about I
didn't write it down go 80 percent
Margaret and so when we looked at junior
high we were looking about 56 percent of
additional needs and we pulled some gym
classes so that we'd have a real
cross-section of the school for junior
high and for senior high and then about
27% in high school so we do see a drop
and there's probably all kinds of
reasons for that and I don't have time
so I'm going to keep going but it was
really it's it's interesting right and
and so when we're trying to look at how
are we creating these in environments
sometimes teachers don't even know
beyond these are identified kids how
many unidentified kids are coming in
with high adverse childhood experiences
that that haven't shown up in any
paperwork kind of manner so the question
is how do we help the adults to start to
look at at how do you create an
environment it's gonna be great for all
of these kids whoever shows up through
your door okay so what we needed to look
at was looking at some frames of
reference that we could put in place to
help adults understand
and what the makeup of the classroom
might be like and what is some of the
things that they're they're seeing what
is some of the rationale behind that or
the reasoning behind it sorry so one of
the first ones working with the
psychology team it's been really helpful
as an educator to be working with
psychology I learned that there are
seven domains of impairment that can be
related to some of that toxic stress and
adversity that we alluded to this
morning
and so areas are listed up here the
attachment piece is huge on how kids are
able to attach all the way down to
number seven with the self-concept so
what we might see is is in a student
maybe they've got problems with
boundaries there could be a high level
of distrust of the adults or other kids
maybe they're not participating in the
classroom physical contact can be a
trigger so we're talking about the
importance of touch wall some kids by
the time they're in school that touch
can be a really adverse experience and
can create some some big responses they
have trouble perhaps expressing or
controlling their emotions and also
following rules and most importantly
with learning right we're in the
business of teaching and learning in
education so if you've got multiple
children fluctuating between all kinds
of challenges daily then knowing that
knowing that this is happening isn't
really enough right so just having that
knowledge that that there's kids coming
to school with lots of challenges and
lots of impairments doesn't really help
us help the student so I had a video
that we were going to try to show you we
had some technical difficulties with it
but Hilary's gonna send the link but the
reason I wanted to show it to you and
it's it's really about the the fight
flight and freeze response and it's a
really good depiction of that and I
wanted to show it to you because the
piece is that we have to help to start
the educators and professionals
understand in a basic way what is it
that we're talking about when we're
talking about this complex science okay
so the link will be sent to you guys and
you can take a look at it
a little creepy I'll tell you that
upfront because they got these little
cartoon characters with these freaky
eyes but so don't be scared but the
message is awesome so do take time to to
look at that so I'll just skip past that
into what the survival response in
schools looks like and so that's your
your fight flight and freeze so we might
see for a student that's going to that
fight place hyperactivity the verbal
aggression oppositional behavior all of
those the flight might be more of that
shutting down or withdrawing escaping
right they're not they're avoiding work
and other things and then the free story
the freeze is that shutting down
emotionally
okay we're we're kind of lights are on
nobody's home how do we reach these kids
in the classroom these things can be
interpreted as this engagement laziness
aggression and that can affect staff
engagement right so if you're kind of
looking again I was hoping to hear a
little bit more from from Tom around
that piece but if your staff engagement
is down then what's the effect long-term
for kids in school right so great news
the great news is the plasticity
information has been really helpful in
my practice and in education to
understand that we're not kind of set
there was kind of a thought you know you
come in the door and grade one with
whatever you're dealing with and you're
gonna go out in grade twelve is sort of
that those same abilities and the
learning that we've had is that we've
got we've got room for change we've got
room to be looking at building those
executive functioning and still building
that prefrontal cortex even if there's a
deficit coming in agreed we always want
it to be prior right the best case
scenario is is that prenatal and before
they ever come to school but it's not
our reality so we got to keep kind of
focused on that and working forward
through it um so we can look at it
instead of as an unsolvable problem but
an opportunity for continued growth and
learning which is super exciting okay
five minutes all right
so first we have to look beyond the
classroom to that whole school system
okay and I think that's where I was
getting caught up when I first started
was going in and narrow
the student that I was advocating for
and working for and working within that
classroom and it's really important to
look at the whole school system and
remembering that it's like an orchestra
so there's many specialized players
throughout an entire school system and
to be in harmony all the players must be
in tune and highly skilled and therein
lies the challenge so how do we keep the
system informed and updated on current
research related to student learning
right we've got a lot of players and
they're listed kind of there at the
bottom just a cross-section right we've
got Board of Trustees we've got parents
we've got legal departments we've got
bus drivers and lunch supervisors along
with our students and teachers and
psychologists our OTS and pts who are
bringing in the brushing into school
which is really great to see so those
all of those players are together and if
they don't have the same information
it's really hard to gain momentum right
so our message I think is around how do
we how do we look at that so one way we
can look at that is through the RTI
model and the RTI model came out of an
academic model around LD and so on which
we do not have time for but in the
behavioral model at the bottom we're
looking at that 80 to 85 percent
it says 95 on here but the 80 to 85 is
talking about those kind of dandy-lion
children right where they're gonna do
well in the systems that we've got set
up the better system we have set up the
better but they're gonna do okay at tier
2 we're looking at at-risk kids who may
need some some further interventions and
then at the top of the of the triangle
there it's about 1 to 5 percent of
students who are really gonna need
intensive intensive individualized
supports okay so what we did was we took
a look at it through the lens of that
orchestra with all the different parts
that need to be together if we're
looking at students if they're at the
top they may have no experience or
exposure to playing an instrument or to
being in an orchestra so we're at a real
deficit they're at tier two they might
be putting it together they're gonna
need some more practice and support
together
and at the bottom are your competent and
talented musicians who are just you
throw them to music and they start
playing okay so if we look at the the
adults as well and we start to figure
out okay if we want to create those that
really great universal environment at
the bottom if the caregivers and
professionals have little to no exposure
on recent research informed
interventions there at that top level
right at the middle they may have been
introduced already to things like brain
architectures serve and return toxic
stress executive function resilience all
of those things might have be knowledge
that they have but in order to create
that environment the application of the
scientific theory has to be mastering
teaching to any of those identified
deficits right and there needs to be
time for that so you get the information
you need to process it you need to
figure out how you're going to apply it
within the setting so and if you're only
one person in a school building that has
that information it can be challenging
so how do we get that to everybody okay
Oh going too far
oh I think just the one other thing that
I wanted to say is making sure that we
understand sort of that middle tier
those pieces everybody in that Orchestra
needs to have that information or some
some sense of understanding so whether
you're a superintendent a parent of us
driver those pieces are important to
have okay
so we need to intentionally provide the
knowledge and tools to create a
welcoming caring safe and respectful
learning environment so that kids can
learn so it's kind of that enriched
environment that we were looking at at
the end of Brian's information so if we
can do that we're hoping and hoping that
we can help that stress response kind of
turn down a little bit so kids can can
learn right because when it's heightened
they're not in space where they can
access the prefrontal cortex and and be
successful as successful in school okay
so some of the challenges are to create
that environment to identify the gaps to
be prepared to deliver age-appropriate
interventions and when I say for early
years and subsequent development and
academic gaps those are things that
happened in the early years okay but
you've got a 16 year old in front of you
who needs some developmental skills he's
functioning maybe he's about 6 ok so how
do we still respect his his 16 year old
age and then be prepared to go back
through those challenges repeatedly oh
my alarms going off so the last slide is
that in order for us to teach there to
reach vulnerable children at school we
have to understand the complexities of
the orchestra that's the school system
and identify the level of understanding
of current research and research and
formed interventions of the audience
that you're trying to reach we have to
work toward creating masterful schools
and nowhere where each stakeholder is on
that RTI triangle model for efficiency
and collaboration right so if you're
aware of kind of what service you're
offering where that might sit that can
help a lot so what do we need we need to
start with the adults to reach the kids
and it truly takes a village so now for
questions anyone in the room with
questions take a mic over to my right
thanks Ike
I really enjoyed your talk that was
really interesting and you're probably
familiar with the jakub's Foundation
which is a big funder of and early
childhood education programs and
different kind of research on the early
educational system and have that can
influence job development one of the
things that they're calling for is
personalize schools and speaks to the
notion of kind of personalized medicine
or precision medicine which is taking
off in in the sciences and you touched
on about that at the end of your talk
what do you think is the the biggest
barrier to us actually being able to
introduce this kind of concept into
education this idea of personalized
personally education programs for
children so it's a it's a great question
and I kind of come from a bit of a maybe
a cheat environment because the school
that I work in is we have really low
numbers of kids so a really high ratio
of staff to student and and so so we're
able to perhaps incorporate more of a
personalized touch than than most
schools I think it kind of goes back to
the slide that I showed you right where
we have twenty four kids in the class in
elementary school with a potential for
up to eighty percent of those kids
having additional needs and that's not
including the unidentified needs right
so it's quite complex I think it's it's
a huge question I think that it's that
it's every teacher's dream to do just
that
and and and so I don't have an answer I
think it's a it's a huge societal sort
of question around that but I I am
thrilled that these kind of
conversations are happening because I
think that's where we'll see some of the
change if you go back to the RTI model
the better job we can do at that
Universal level of being really
masterful around how we're creating
those environments for kids when we see
that happening we see the numbers shift
a bit so we see those kids that are
receiving the targeted interventions be
able to shift down into that bottom
level right I've been into schools where
that whole triangle was upside down
right where the red was huge
and you had like these little bit of
targeted kids and a little bit of green
and with real focus on that Universal
level you can start to shift those
numbers so I think that that's where we
always say we'd like to start is how do
we help get the message out so that
schools can do a really good job of
trying to create that that entry point
at the universal level so that those
numbers that the targeted and the and
individualized shrink a bit and become
more manageable right I hope that helps
we have a question online if you could
take the mic over to any
Vicki Harbor is wondering if anyone
knows if teacher preparation programs
university courses are being introduced
to this information or if schools are
actually having an opportunity to offer
PD to teachers on this hi Vicki I think
that I I'm not I can't answer to the
University piece I know that we have
seen some so maybe someone else can jump
in in the crowd I know we've seen some
teachers coming out of UC with some
exposure to some trauma courses things
like that where they're getting a bit of
exposure around that those effects on
the brain and development and as far as
as teacher access again I think it's
becoming more common it's kind of
exciting when I first started talking
about this I teach some kind of side
courses at shouldna clearning for adults
and when I first started all of this
information was brand-new to people and
they would be shocked and surprised and
I just did one a few weeks ago and it
was amazing the folks coming in were
predominantly predominantly school lunch
supervisors EA's educational assistants
and so on and they had the basics it was
really cool so it's coming around where
they're starting to understand that
piece of building relationship really
building those safe environments and
starting to understand the effects on on
development when we don't take the time
to do that so there are some courses out
there but it will depend on where you're
at and and who you can access yeah Brian
there are a lot of PD days that I've
spoken at I've spoken at the ATA in
Edmonton we'll be speaking again in
kananaskis a terrestrial s bridge has a
master's program in education and
neuroscience two-year summer program so
these things are are appearing okay well
have time I remind you again for
questions for all of the panelists at
the end